pour être complet à présent nous
revenons sur les réactions des autres
formations qui totalisent moins de 5 %
au niveau national avec vous nicolas
landry alors justement parmi tous ces
petits candidat c'est nicolas dupont
aignan qui est arrivé en tête dans le
département avec 4 34% des voix un
résultat un résultat largement supérieur
à ses 1,73 % obtenus lors des élections
présidentielles de 2012 dans le
département cette hausse pourrait
notamment s'expliquer par le basculement
de certains électeurs des républicains
vers le parti debout la france je vous
propose d'écouter la présidente
d'honneur de la fédération yves
guinoiseau notre première réaction a été
extrêmement positive parce que les
chiffres ont montré une veut une énorme
progression dlf et en plus c'est à peu
près homogène dans tout le temps tout le
territoire n'y a pas deux bastions
particulier dont il ya une vraie
poussette font la plus large audience de
nicolas dupont aignan a fait que les
gens l'ont mieux entendu long mieux
compris et aussi se sont rendus compte
qu'il y avait d'autres votes qui était
peut-être moins intéressants et qu'il
fallait peut-être être aller au fond des
choses il ya un autre candidat qui
portait un discours eurosceptiques c'est
françois asselineau à l'indépendance de
la france c'était la thématique de
campagne de françois asselineau le
candidat de l'union populaire
républicaine obtient près d'un pour cent
des voix dans les yvelines un résultat
meilleur qu'au niveau national comme on
peut le voir sur cette image avec 0,92
pour cent il ya certaines communes on a
même fait deux ans et demi 3 % au haut
niveau par rapport au niveau national on
est très légèrement au dessus donc non
il n'y a pas lieu de se glorifier de
d'un résultat qui est très faible par
rapport aux espérances que beaucoup
nourri sec
la position comme celle du mouvement
c'est que monsieur macron c'est la
catastrophe et que madame le pen c'est
la catastrophe
en tout cas si vous évoquez les ce qu'on
appelle les consignes de vote
bon c'est quelque chose auquel on croit
absolument pas de toute façon on n'est
pas propriétaire des voix de nos
électeurs autres candidats qui
participait pour la première fois à
l'élection présidentielle c'est jean
lassalle au niveau national il gagne
environ 1% des suffrages durant sa
campagne le béarnais a défendu la
ruralité et les territoires indices tout
qu un discours qui a recueilli les voix
de 0,71 % de l'électorat yvelinois
les yvelines le score de 0 71% et est un
très bon score dans une région qui est
assez peu proches en terme d'idées de
celle de jean lassalle
ça représente c'est ça à peu près ça ni
de sané d'électeurs c'est beaucoup c'est
l'équivalent d'une ville comme big donc
ça prouve que là aussi le message de
trouver un ancrage candidats présents en
2012 philippe poutou le représentant du
nouveau parti anticapitaliste avaient
totalisé 0 81% il est sensiblement dans
la même fourchette avec 0 72 % cette
année écouter son représentant dans le
département pour les événements pareils
qu'on ferait un score très bon chef de
la droite n'étant pas vraiment déçu
on appellera pas appellera l'attention
bon levin on présentera pas lutte
ouvrière et nathalie arthaud son score
dans les yvelines
c'est la stabilité pour lutte ouvrière
dans les yvelines nathalie arthaud a
réalisé un score légèrement en dessous
des 0 4% comme en 2012
une satisfaction pour les militants ils
vont pour poursuivre le combat pour
faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
notamment durant les élections
législatives prochaines étapes pour
encore une fois nous nous nous montrez
nous faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs et continuer cette campagne
qu'on a commencé de depuis quelques mois
et pouvoir toujours aller vers ces
travailleurs pour leur expliquer
justement ben que cette société va
falloir la changer que pour la changer
ça sera pas au travers du vote ça sera
pas au travers du futur président de la
future présidente qui de toute façon un
mènerons une politique contre les
travailleurs pour finir le représentant
de solidarité et progrès jacques
cheminade recueille 0 18 % au niveau
national mais le score dans les yvelines
candidat en 2012 il perd près de 700
voix dans le département une déception
pour son représentant yvelinois j'aurais
attendu quand même plus de résultats
étant donné qu'il ya pas mal de gens qui
nous ont dit qu'ils s'intéressaient à
ses idées donc le problème c'est que
beaucoup de gens voter en pour ceux qui
gagnent donc par exemple beaucoup de
gens disaient qu'ils allaient voter
mélenchon alors qu'il préférait jacques
cheminade
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'à l'avenir
ces gens-là agissent avec nous quoi
plutôt que de à chaque fois se laisser
avoir
et pour les législatives on veut avoir
le plus possible de candidats ça
dépendra des moyens financiers qu'on
aura parce qu'on n'a pas un financement
public aux législatives contrairement
aux présidentielles si nicolas pour ces
précisions concernant les plus petits
candidats c'est ainsi qu'ils ont été
appelés pendant cette campagne ainsi
également stéphane profonde et appelé à
commenter ces différents résultats
notamment dans le département des
yvelines tous les résultats sur notre
site internet ainsi et que l'intégralité
des réactions des représentants des
candidats replay aussi sur notre
application mobile les programmes se
poursuivre sur téléphiles